[Musique]
oh chérie tu m'as fait peur attends tu
pris une photo ou tu es en train de
filmer là je t'ai bien eu hein
sérieusement chérie je suis même pas
maquillée papa regarde j'ai trouvé un
pain au chocolat il est très mignon ça
fait du bien d'être avec vous oh mon
amour merci de Têtre libéré pour passer
du temps avec nous mais qu'est-ce
[Musique]
quequez-vousquez-vous ch rest tout
monde chérie
et c'est ainsi que j'ai chappa à l'enfer
et que je suis devenu le seul survivant
d'une race perdue depuis j'ai juré de me
venger par tous les moyens et c'est pour
ça que j'ai besoin de vous nous devons
avertir tout le monde que la plus grande
menace que l'univers est connue est en
marche ben dis donc votre vie c'est pas
du gâteau
[Musique]
1 2 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le temps a passé depuis notre dernière
aventure contre Sylvain le roi des elfes
Sylvain nous étions tous réunis il y
avait le Py
barbare l'enfant de juron chère maman ça
va dans les couilles du cul c'est
beaucoup laabit par là-bas le hbit mais
je suis pas un hobbit un hobbit
et les patte voilà qui était
surprenant regardez Mo qu élégance tout
se passe bien le calme est revenu et
nous pouvons enfin apprécier un repos
bien
mérité monsieur le vieux sage non non
c'est lui non non je petit et poilu j'ai
quelque chose pour
vous ça vient tout juste d'arriver
papier m sens de cambriour m' qu'il y a
probablement quelque chose
d'écrit pas PRR
[Musique]
ici merci d'avoir fait confiance aux
Amazon
chien écout les
amis miss qui nous a été adressé indune
grande épre Magi est sur le point de
commencerur nous av nelle qu nous dev
les bordel de Chi ça tire dans les
pompes à chiotes il marque un point les
garsarot c'est quand même super loin je
veux pas être lou mais comment on fait
pour y aller alors qu'on n'a pas une
tune il va nous falloir des armes des
vivres des chevaux j'ai peut-être une
solution il se trouve que mes parents
sont très riche et que justement j'ai
peut-être une solution je donne toujours
mon avis même quand on me le demande pas
et vous savez ces petites secoupe là
pour les ver parce que sinon c'est
dégueulass mais enfin mais qui a besoin
de tout merdier dans le clan des
pyarbares on a toujours dit alors oui
c'est vrai qu'on est fauché mais il n
reste ces petits machins qu'on a piqué à
syvin il y a peut-être moyen d'en tirer
un bon
[Musique]
prix et pourquoi tu t'arrêtes si je joue
une note de plus on va devir payer les
droits
alors pris un truc
[Musique]
allez rendez-vous allez quoi on arrête
les méchanceté hein non mais parce qu'on
est gentil nous s'il vous plaît le
commissaire ensuite il va nous cronderer
et
puis
e B qu'est-ce qui se passe ch tu as
changé les pile qui tu as changé les
pile
[Musique]
ouais laboratoire de drogue terroriste
cours de yoga des terroristes bonjour
bonjour
[Musique]
vous les mains en l'air canille où jou
volant les
plumes
ah bah je crois qu'on arrive trop tard
commissaire canarman a déjà fait tout le
boulot ah B je crois qu'on arrive trop
tard commissaire déjà fait tout le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
boulot c'est réglé commissaire on a
enfin pu démeler ce laboratoire de
drogue bon boulot les gars non c'est
c'est de la
cajou encore une affaire réglée
commissaire canard City est à nouveau en
sécurité pas exactement monsieur man
ah je travaille au
gouvernement je travaille pour une
organisation gouvernementale extrêmement
secrète le carapace pour centre
d'armement et de réponse aux attaques
pour l'amitié des copains
extraterrestres
attendez des
extraterrestres non ah ok c'est cool
alors le but principal de notre
organisation est d'empêcher une Atta
exratrestre c'est pour ça que j'infiltré
ce groupe de criminels dans l'espoire de
vous
rencontrer ça fait combien de temps que
vous m'attendez 2 ans 6 mois et 7 jours
j'ai fait des choses terribles mais mais
vous êtes qui d'abord je suis Nick furis
et si vous voulez en savoir plus prenez
cette
[Musique]
brochure les amis nous arriverons très
bientôt à la frontière de cercasland
n devons la traverser afin d'atteindre
le Donon de S mais ce sont des teres
maudites il y a pas moyen de contourner
si ça va plus long on va faire comment
du
coup laiss l'enfant de juron
décider du pu dans la
chatte qu' en soitsi
[Musique]
nous y sommes laissez-moi NG ohà
voyageur la frontière de sarcassland est
fermée on sait pas trop pourquoi mais
bon ça nous arrange au niveau du scénard
et puis bon je suppose que vous
évidemment vous voulez quand même passer
parce que sinon on serait tous bloqués
là comme des cons et la vidéo elle
avancerait
plus bon vous inquiétez pas parce que
comme par hasard comme par hasard hasard
comme par hasard il y a un moyen de
passer merde alors mais c'est super
étonnant ça oh je sais pour passer ça va
être une espèce d'épreuve oh dans le
c'est un génie ce mec bon je fais durer
le suspense mais tout le monde a compris
que l'épreuve ça allait être un jeu
vidéo oh mais c'est fou ça vous trouvez
pas et puis ça tombe bien comme par
hasard par hasard on a une télé dans la
tente et on t'a fait un joli décord ouis
on est au Moyen-Âge mais on s'en fout on
a l'électricité hein j'ai une prise la
branche dans mon cul dans ton cul dans
ton cul j'allais j'allais la faire allez
hop la prise de terre
allez e je je je suppose que le jeu là
ça va être un super jeu dépêchonsnous
enfant de juron cet endroit est
insupportable Dark Souls quand on entend
ce nom on l'associe toujours à une
difficulté horrible vous êtes perdu dans
un donjon il y a des centaines de
monstres il faut apprendre leurs pattern
il faut cartographier le monde et c'est
affreusement dur et ben Dark Souls c'est
pour les petites merdes vous voulez rter
du sang essayez plutôt deadly Towers
deadly Towers est sorti en décembre 86
presque 12 mois après le premier Zelda
le jeu est très certainement un des jeux
les plus ambitieux de la Ness à la base
un jeu japonais il a été ensuite racheté
par des Américains qui voulai en faire
un concurrent direct à la franchise
Zelda et mine de rien il s'est très bien
vendu mais pourtant ce jeu a été reconnu
comme un des jeux les plus frustrants de
laanesse pourquoi on va voir ça tout de
suite
le jeu commence sur un long texte
d'introduction pour nous expliquer
l'histoire il s'agit d'une vieille
vieille histoire d'un âge de pierre et
de cuivre un âge où vivent les hommes et
les diables alors que la cérémonie de
couronnement approche le prince Mayer
devent nerveux depuis le je bon allez
nique ta mère bref c'est un long
texte c'est quoi ça une F fille d'Harry
Potter allez plus vite mais merde on
dirait les pavés que poste certains mecs
dans la section commentaire de YouTube
c'était pour les enfants je rappelle à
la base les jeux et en plus pour l'avoir
lu ça pourrait se résumer à votre
personnage va devenir roi mais il y a un
méchant qui arrive qui veut détruire le
monde donc vous allez l'arrêter parce
qu'à ce compte- là je peux vous écrire
un de pavé d'introduction sur
Super Mario Bros mais ça sera pas plus
intéressant hein vous êtes fait chier à
tout lire hein c'est ça deadly Towers
est donc un action RPG tout à fait
classique vous contrôlez un personnage
qui peut bouger dans les h directions ce
qui est assez rare pour le noter sur
nest parce que même Zelda n'avait que
quatre directions vous évoluez dans des
tours d'où le titre Towers pour tour 11
an expérience vous y affronterez plein
d'ennemis différents tel des dragons
avec des boucliers des hommes tigres des
chevaliers noirs des loupgarous bon
alors ça c'était les idées du carad
designer le lundi à 8h après un bon café
un bon weekend et les enfants chez Mamie
maintenant si tu reviens le vendredi à
17h50 c'est plus la même parce qu'en
réalité on affrontera surtout des trucs
genre des flaques des ronds et qu'est-ce
que c'est sensé représenter ça des
mouches des pixels qui volent à un
moment ça va hein quand tu bosses dans
le jeu vidéo qu'on demande de créer des
ennemis et que tu rends ça il y a un
moment faut envisager une reconversion
ah non non non c'est un ennemi
totalement justifié regardez on l'a noté
dans le livret c'est un ber il rebondit
comme une balle OK et ça c'est quoi ah
oui ah ça c'est un CRUD il ressemble à
un liquide mais sortez de chez moi très
bien à bientôt comment ça à
bientôt le bouton A permet de tirer des
épées qui on d'ailleurs ce truc chiant
classique des jeux rétro de ne pouvoir
tirer qu'une épée à la fois c'està-dire
qu'il faut attendre que l'épée sorte de
l'écran pour pouvoir tirer la seconde ce
qui du coup vous oblige à toujours
coller aux ennemis pour pouvoir spammer
les coups et je pense que vous vous
doutez tous que danser le Zook avec un
dragon ça risque de mal finir le bouton
B sert à jeter les items dans le menu et
le bouton Select justement vous envoie
vers votre inventaire inventaire qui
indique votre nombre de cloches vos
points de vie et votre nombre de lodeur
alors ça je sais pas trop ce que ça veut
dire de secondes très bien votre
nombre de donc wou ah ça fait
quand même beaucoup de salop d'ailleurs
vos sal enfin vos leur vous serviront à
acheter des objets mais très vite on se
rend compte qu'il y a un problème avec
les objets de ce jeu genre là je viens
d'acheter un petit bonhomme j'ai cliqué
dessus il a
disparu
et on peut m'expliquer il s'est passé
quoi en fait tu es
librepjà de base rien que sur l'objectif
général du jeu il y a un problème je
veux dire le but du jeu c'est de
retrouver cette cloche et de les brûler
en terme de logique déjà ça commence mal
oui et après avoir brûlé les cloches il
faut souffler dans le
parchemin et ce genre de bêtise arrive
avec tous les items du jeu alors vous me
direz dans les vieux jeux normalement ce
genre de chose était marqué sur le
livret et bien regardons les amis
figurine les effets de ceci sont inconnu
masse magique l'effet de la masse
magique n'est pas connu clé magique vous
devez trouver vous-même à quoi elle sert
waouh c'est c'est qui c'est l'assistance
technique de SFR qui a écrit ce truc et
la clé magique dans le jeu en plus on
l'a trouvé et tu pourrait te dire que
bah je sais pas une clé ça servirait
genre au hasard ouvrir une porte mais
non cette clé ser à ouvrir une porte qui
était déjà ouvert c'est juste que quand
tu Lares sur toi les gardes qui étaient
devant la porte se poussent tu peux pas
faire plus confus vous comprenez le
principe de serrure bande de guigno bon
après si ce jeu a gagné son titre de jeu
le plus frustrant de la Neste il y a
bien une raison en réalité le jeu n'est
pas juste idiot avec ses objets à la con
le jeu est surtout
stupidement
dur par exemple le jeu est trufé de
passage secret
voilà jeavez pas vu non non c'était pas
un cut dans le montage je suis
réellement passé par un passage secret
attendez j'en mets un autre
voilà a toujours rien c'est normal c'est
secret en gros pour résumer au début du
jeu vous allez alterner entre les
passages extérieurs qui utilisent cette
espèce de scrolling de merde qui te
colle le nez au bord de l'écran et les
parties donjon dont les entrées sont
secrète le problème c'est qu'elles sont
tellement secrètes que pour les trouver
il faut fouiller littéralement chaque
de pixel du jeu alors s'il y en a
parmi vous qui veulent se lancer dans ce
métier formidable qui est le jeu vidéo
pitié pitié avant d'aller faire une
école de programmation de game design de
ce que vous voulez s'il vous plaît allez
à l'école primaire comme ça vous ne
confondrez pas le mot secret et le mot
invisible d'ailleurs anecdote ils ont
même réussi à justifier dans le scénare
les entrées invisible la résonance des
SEP cloches a créé un espace distordu
qui a rendu invisible les entrées des
donjons pièces secrètes et monde
parallèle j'adore ce genre de connerie
tu peux tout justifier oui très bien
mais concernant les retraites écoutez la
résonance des SEP cloches bref du coup
merci la résonance de cette cloche grâce
à toi pour fouiller les donjons on doit
gratter le ah
la chier dans la
il a l'air de bien s'abuser deadly
Tower tel une femme en scène qui
mettrait du craque sur sa brosse à dent
et se demande ensuite pourquoi son gosse
ressemble à Albator a eu une série
d'idées génial pendant sa conception la
première chaque fois que votre
personnage est touché celui-ci subit un
mouvement de recul mais ce mouvement de
recul n'est pas toujours dans la
direction du coup prix non la plupart du
temps le recul vous fait aller
uniquement vers le bas de l'écran ce qui
donne lieu à des intenses moments de
démonstration de joie notamment quand
vous marchez près d'un gouffre
marbit cou et quel jeu
de peur de ça veut rien dire de se faire
pousser un truc qui vient tons merde et
ces démonstrations de joie se
transforment ensuite rapidement en un
furieux désir charnel de caresser les
murs avec votre crâne quand dans les
donjons le jeu vous fait reculer à
travers des portes ou là non par là il y
a trop de
[Musique]
monde la seconde idée géniale c'est que
le jeu ne possède aucune frameme
d'invincibilité une frame
d'invincibilité vous savez forcément ce
que c'est il s'agit dans un jeu vidéo
d'un court lapse de temps après avoir
été touché par un ennemi où vous ne
pouvez pas reprendre de dégâts dans les
vieux jeux en général ça se manifestait
par votre personnage qui clignote et ça
sert surtout à éviter que toute
l'énergie que tu auras mis plusieurs
dizaines de minutes à récupérer en tuant
des monstres en boucle dans une même
salle se fasse pomper en une demi-seonde
derrière une porte comme si c'était le
jour des
[Musique]
Imposs j'ai envie de me mordre la
et enfin à tout ce que je viens de dire
he tu rajoutes du sel et du poivre genre
la perspective qui n'a aucun sens
puisque j'arrive à me mettre devant eux
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a une
profondeur mais en même temps non il y
en a pas parce que je peux pas passer
derrière enfin BF c'est du génie ou
d'autres menus détail du type alors je
sais pas si c'est mon personnage qui
frappe comme un végétarien ou si c'est
les ballons de plage dans ce jeu qui
sont ultra balaises ou d'autres trucs du
genre les ennemis qui te one shot en
sortant des portes
les les gars vous saviez vous pouviez
juste aller prendre une batte de
baseball et aller éclater des crâne
d'enfant dans une maternelle ça irait
plus vite et personnellement je trouve
ça moins
cruel après c'est vrai qu'il suffit de
pas grand-chose pour transformer ça en
bon jeu tu changes la vue de face par
une vue classique histoire d'arranger la
perspective tu enlèves cette idée de
merde de l'épée en rajoutant juste une
vraie épée tu rajoutes des frames
d'invulnérabilité et des cœurs plus
faciles à farmmer pour que ça soit
jouable
et et voilà là c'est bien ah c'est fou
que personne n'a eu l'idée de faire un
jeu comme ça alors j'ai également pas
précisé mais en général qui dit donjon
dit labyrinthe ce qui est pas étonnant
mais heureusement le jeu est généreux et
vous donne la carte dans le livret du
premier
[Musique]
labyrinthe les donjons dans ce jeu sont
inf
c'est les chiottes du fun tenez regardez
une carte d'un donjon de
Zelda ok donc prenons une autre carte
même le plus grand des donjons de Zelda
la montagne de la mort qui est le donjon
final du jeu c'était une cinquantaine de
pièces ici rien que le premier donjon
dont la carte est gentiment fournie sur
le livret à
167 pièces le deuxème donjon en a
235 regardez cette horreur
dirit des de mots croisés c'est
le donjon 2 il y en a 10 alors oui je
sais que ça a l'air dur mais
heureusement le jeu a un bon conseil
pour nous oui regardez faites des
cartes voilà c'est simple tu as entendu
Billy fais les cartes merci notice
reading mais après ne vous inquiétez pas
la plupart des pièces ne servent à rien
regardez en vert c'est le chemin et en
jaune c'est tout le reste et quand je
parle de chemin je ne parle pas de
chemin qui vous mènerait jusqu'à un boss
comme dans un RPG classique ou là non
dans des Tower les donjons te servent
uniquement à trouver des magasins qui te
servent à acheter de l'équipement pour
te préparer à faire les vrais donjons
les tours et oui les tours le nom du jeu
parce que les cloches à brûlé là le but
du jeu dont je parlais tout à l'heure
elles ne sont pas dans les donjons elles
sont dans les tours donc au final les
donjons c'est juste l'apéritif la TE
techniquement j'ai même pas encore
commencé le jeu arrête il n pas chargé
en gros le jeu est divisé comme tel le
monde extérieur qu'on appelle le château
qui comprend neu étages dans ces neuf
étages il y a 10 donjons qu'il faut
faire pour ramasser de l'équipement en
haut du 9e étage il y a se entrées
chaque entrée mène à une tour chaque
tour mène à une autre tour en haut de
chaque tour il y a un boss chaque boss
lâche une cloche qui doit être ensuite
ramené en refaisant
tout le chemin en sens inverse jusqu'au
9e étage pour y être brûlé et
laissez-moi réfléchir est-ce que j'ai
envie de m'infliger
ça il y en a encore j'ai même pas parlé
des zones parallèles ou en gros vous
prenez tout ce dont je viens de vous
parler ét château dont j'orte tout et
vous le dupliquer en mettant plus de
[Musique]
monstres pareil pour les secret room qui
sont encore d'autres pièces caché qui te
permet de récupérer encore plus de
[Musique]
matos écoutez pas de souci devant ce
genre de difficulté on se calme on
réfléchit et on analyse juste la
trajectoire de chaque ennemi allez
dégage à côté de ce jeu Dark Souls c'est
à dibout sachez aussi que à chaque fois
que vous tuez un des boss en haut d'une
tour le jeu entier devient plus
difficile certains magasins
disparaissent ce qui limite ta
possibilité d'acheter des des potions de
vie et en prime les ennemis vont plus
vite ont plus de PV et font plus mal
quoi vous aviez peur que votre jeu soit
trop facile c'est ça d'ailleurs anecdote
à la con en 2006 Shun baby un espèce de
proto AVGN qui faisait des critiques de
jeux pourris sur son blog a publié un
article sur deadly Towers un développeur
du jeu est alors venu répondre sur
l'article et a déclaré dans une
interview nous on a beaucoup testé le
jeu on trouvveit pas que c'était si
difficile que ça
[Musique]
ah enfant de juron y a-til eu de
l'avancement dans ta quête miss a vomi
sur mes
couilles c'est c'est terrible il ne
reste alors qu'un seul moyen pour
réussir à passer oh tiens regardez
quelle surprise ils vont nous attaquer
maintenant oh bah oui évidemment comme
ça le scénario il avance ou puis on est
des chevaliers on a les épées et tout
mais évidemment on va opposer aucune
résistance non d'ailleurs laisse-moi te
filer un coup de main puisque de toute
façon on est déjà mort ou per tu dis la
carotide allez on y va allez oh benah
voilà il est mort oh bah oui FL je suis
mort oh bah non merde regardez la tente
est en train de prendre peur c'est quand
même un super timing ah mais dis donc
chevalier c'est pas ici qu'on stocké la
poudre par
hasard oh non c'est trop con ça regardez
j'ai pris feu et ma peau est en train de
fondre mais c'est horrible non c'est la
dure loi de la
ue avez-vous déjà rêvé d'une agence
gouvernementale qui vous protège des
extraterrestres une agence qui vous
permette de retrouver le tonus et la
vitalité de votre
jeunesse
carapace profitez pleinement de toutes
les offres de notre centre de remise en
forme spa Amam circuit découverte
luminothérapie une température de 29°g
toute l'année et une protection sans
faille contre les menaces
extraterrestres moi je vais à Caracas et
moi je vais à
[Applaudissements]
carapace on est 5 alors non on partage
nos locau avec la Faculté des Métiers eu
ils sont pas dans l'équipe bonjour du
coup on est que deux non vous oubliez le
vieroi
frus je me battrai pour venger ma
famille et ma planète donc on est deux
plus une galette galette un peu de
respect vous adressz un vétéran de la
guerre deer vous pas changé un peu de
tête vous on a eu plus de budget vous
pourriez faire un peu moins de bruit et
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici
justement une cassette pour ça
[Musique]
aussi bonjour les amis bonjour Nick
bonjour Nick bonjour bonjour bonjour
coucou oui Nick notre président est bel
et bien François
mitan mais dis donc Nick mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ici bien aujourd'hui nous
allons parler des gemes de pouvoir GEM
de pouvoir mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce truc
oh bonjour les copains je suis monsieur
j'im laissez-moi vous présenter mes amis
ils sont trois j'aime jaune j'aime bleu
et j'aime verte verte tout seul je ne
sers pas à grand-chose mais quand nous
sommes toutes les quatre réunies nous
pouvons exaucer n'importe quelle veut
n'importe quelle veut comme détruire
l'univers et oui j'aime jaune détruire
l'univers
détruire alors trouve nous toutes les
quatre
sinon on va détruire l'univers et le
réuire en poussière on va détruire
l'univers ça veut dire aussi la
[Musique]
terre des questions alors oui non vous
ça vous concerne pas c'est extrêmement
grave qui est au courant de ça alors
seulement les personnes présentes dans
cette piè
et aussi toutes celles qui ont participé
à la réalisation de cette vidéo ça ça ça
fait beaucoup de monde qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire canarman nous avons besoin de
vous un terrible ennemi a déjà deux
gemmes en sa possession vous avez par le
passé eu affaire à ces gemmes et vous
possédez toutes les consoles nécessaires
à leur récupération vous m'z fait venir
juste pour ça vous connaissez le prix
des consoles rétro sur ebay on est le
gouvernement à pas Squeezie quoi c'est
vraiment ce guignol là qui est censé
sauver l'univers prenier peut-être
devriez-vous prouver au viceroi fr j'ai
pas votre valeur j'ai justement une
cartouche qui nous permettra de calibrer
nos instruments d'accord donc il faut
que je trouve quelque chose à la
galette
[Musique]
Batman Forever Batman et Robin
Superman 64 Catwoman Aquaman les jeux
X-Men les jeux Spider-Man les quat
fantastiques Silver Surfer pendant ces
11 dernières années nous avons testé
mout jeu tiré de comics et à force on
commence à avoir pas mal gratté la
cuvette mais il reste toujours cette
petite trace vous savez au fond là qui
s'accroche alors tu pisses dessus tu
pisses dessus et ça reste là attends on
parle toujours de jeux vidéo là et un
héros qu'on a jamais abordé par contre
c'est Hulk créé par Stanley et Jack
Kirby en 1962 largement inspiré du
personnage de DC Solomon Grundy
l'histoire vous la connaissez tous lors
d'un accident dans une base militaire le
docteur Bruce Banner est exposé à des
rayons gamins et devient impuissant
cancer des couilles fin
[Musique]
d'histoireon évidemment c'est un comic
he il devient Hulk un géant vert
invincible à la force surpuissante alors
c'est sûr que par rapport à Spider-Man
ou à X-Men Hulk a eu beaucoup moins
d'adaptation mais il y en a quand même
eu un petit paquet la grande majorité
des jeux hulques sont arrivés avec la
sortie du film de 2003 et à part une ou
deux bonnes pépites notamment avec
ultimate destruction qui mélanger
savamment bagarre et infiltration
oui non non tout va bien ce camion qui
marche est 100 % réglementaire le reste
des jeux c'était tout juste moyen
notamment sur console portable mais on a
aussi eu quelques jeux sortis avant le
retour en force de Marvel à la fin des
années 2000 un des premiers vrais jeux
Hulk arriva assez tard en 94 sur
SuperNet et megga drive un jeu de
plateforme classique dans le genre de ce
qui se faisait à l'époque on y joue Hulk
qui se déplace comme s'il voulait se
rendre chez le directeur ah bah ce
coupci la caissière elle va m'entendre
hein et vous devrez sauver le monde du
terrible joli petit cul vous pouvez donc
saisir les ennemis leur mettre des coups
de tête des hupercutes vous avez en haut
une barre de gamma qui sert également de
barre de vie avec différents paliers
plus votre barrete grâce
au plus vous infligez de dégâts et à
l'inverse plus vous prenez des coups
plus Hul se calme parce que c'est bien
connu que quand quelqu'un est énervé une
petite savette derrière la nuque là
d'ailleurs chose originale pour l'époque
quand vous arrivez très bas en énergie
vous ne mourrez pas non à la place vous
vous retransformer en Bruce Banner
et
attendez non
mais ils peuvent pas me toucher je peux
littéralement esquiver tous les ennemis
du jeu en jouant Bruce B c'est
littéralement plus facile de jouer Bruce
Banner que Hulk c'est quoi ces ennemis
mon armée de robot va conquérir le
monde et puis ma fois c'est bien mieux
de les esquiver en réalité parce que les
ennemis dans ce jeu mettre 5 à 10 coups
pour
mourir allez
ah mais allez sérieux le mec il soulève
des montagnes détruit des dimensions
mais cass un GRI en moins de 2 minutes
c'est trop compliqué et chaque fois que
je tape un ennemi il recule ce qui le
met hors de portée lui Perm de retirer
dessus et dans ce jeu vous NZ que TR
vies et aucun continue votre priorité
est de conserver votre vie au maximum du
coup voilà comment je suis censé jouer
retrouve votre nouveau comics de
superhéros préfér l'incroyablement
prudent bref au milieuveau terit
l'abomination et ça ressemble
effectivement à un vrai combat de boss
ce qui fait effectivement une bonne
nouvelle mais il y a d'autres boss
puisque dans les niveaux suivants vous
affronterez également l'abomination
ainsi que l'abomination puis encore
l'abomination et pour finir laissez-moi
deviner oui
l'abomination bref donc le jeu c'est ça
boss etnemi plateforme boss ennemi
plateforme
[Musique]
merde jusqu'à atteindre le dernier
niveau qui se passe
dans le cul du méchant génial j'ai
toujours voulu voir ça Hulk contre les
vers de terre ah oui incroyable dernier
boss d'ailleurs quelle imagination c'est
un cerveau qui crache des cerveaux e et
vous croyez qu'on peut dire qu'il a la
tête dans le
cul e pourquoi il y a pas la musique
rigolote et tu oses demander bref le jeu
est peut-être pas folichon certes mais
il reste dans cette espèce de moyenne
base de beaucoup de jeux de cette époque
mais revenons plutôt sur la métaphore de
la cuvette non non Hulk the Panthéon
saga sur Playstation 1 sorti en 1996 un
jeu passé totalement inaperçu à sa
sortie et au passage excellent choix de
bruitage pour les menus
[Musique]
c'est c'est très Hulk dans sa période
princesse d'ailleurs on connait dans le
son avant même de commencer à jouer il
faut bien que je vous parle du sound
design de ce jeu alors déjà niveau
musique bon alors dans la première
partie du niveau 1 ça
[Musique]
va mais
subitement alors oui ça c'est un
domineur mais il y a plein d'autres
touches sur le clavier vous savez
hésitez pas à utiliser les autres hein
et puis je sais pas mais tout les sons
sont dans une qualité dégueulasse genre
le niveau 1 est rempli de trucs en ver à
péter mais le son on dirait tu sais
quand tu vas jeter des bouteilles dans
le conteneur du verre
là vous savez maintenant depuis que je
suis SDF c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour moi de faire mon métier et je suis
désolé je fais chier une dernière fois
avec le son mais regardez ma piste de
montage la moitié des effets
satur donc vous contrôlez Hulk et
évolueer dans un environnement
intégralement en 3D vous devrez
simplement progresser à travers les cinq
niveaux labyrinthiques et battre ennemy
et boss qui se présenteront devant vous
vous avez plusieurs moves he coup de
point coups de pied divers coups
spéciaux qui consomment des rayons gamma
comme dans le jeu megga Drive et le
principe au niveau de l'histoire c'est
que vous allez tabasser plein de gens
très connus de l'univers de Marvel comme
Hector Ulis ou même Atalanta même
Atalanta c'est pas semblant de savoir
qui c'est l'idée est donc de les
tabasser jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent
vos potes
[Musique]
comme dans la vraie vie attends tu tu
m'as jamais tapé à moi non mais je t'ai
déjà tiré dessus tu es comment frère et
à la fin du niveau 1 vous arrivez au
premier boss le terrible
Ajax c'est lui je suis coincé aidez-moi
quoi vous êtes déçu attendez vous
inquiétez pas les prochains vous allez
kiffer on a Lazarus
Truma me dis pas qu'il a pis oui Seb oui
il il y a aussi pisem je savais que ce
jour viendrait bon alors c'est bien tout
ça on rigole bien mais par contre Ajax
il me ruine le cul il me défonce mais
mais pourquoi tout le monde est
plus fort que moi dans ce jeu merde il
ferappe plus fort il a un milliard de
points de vie il bloque tous les coups
il tape de tellement loin qu'il a même
pas besoin de me toucher en
fait bref donc maintenant attention il
faut suivre dans cette salle donc vous
êtes enfermé avec le boss qui est genre
beaucoup trop fort pour vous impossible
de l'approcher ou de le directement et
un bouton ce bouton lorsqu'on clique
dessus fait de la pluie alors est-ce que
je dois le faire tomber dans la rivière
non est-ce que je dois l'attirer contre
les murs pour qu'il glisse se blesse
tout seul non est-ce que la pluie le
fait rouiller peut-être c'est juste
qu'il faut rester en vie le plus
longtemps possible non jeter les caisses
sur le bouton lui faire charger le
bouton mais et mais mais je do
faire quoi avec ce bouton de merde et la
bonne réponse est ou après vérification
sur le net ce bouton n'a aucune utilité
rien
nada alors juste pourquoi la ici mais on
est où là en centre de
TASS brume de printemps rose et matinal
et du coup comment je bat ce de
boss de s Mor et sa vie remonte en plus
c'est
impossible c'est infaisable j'ai tout
essayé tout et on est au niveau 1 au
niveau 1 honnêtement on a même été tenté
de laisser tomber et de vous mettre des
images de Let's Play trouvé sur Youtube
mais la seule vidéo d'Internet entier où
quelqu'un se déteste assez pour aller
plus loin que le premier niveau c'est un
vieux let's play russe de 3000 vu qui en
plus triche pour passer le boss et quand
même d'obscur let's play rus sans s'en
réduit à tricher oh BO et en réalité ce
boss ben c'est un peu comme un
avertissement sur la suite du jeu tu
sais genre laisse tomber remets ce jeu
dans sa boîte va plutôt dehors fumer des
clopes en gros dans ce jeu chaque fois
que tu arrives dans un nouvel endroit tu
as une mécanique obscure et complètement
stupide qu'il faut deviner sans le
moindre indice genre le niveau 2 au
début il y a un boss vous devez deviner
qu'il faut attirer sur vous les boules
de feu tiré par un mec invincible qui
tourne à l'étage du dessus et dont la
caméra ne vous laisse apercevoir qu'un
morceau des pieds et se servir de ces
boules de feu pour péter des carrés
rouges au sol qui apparemment étaient
des interrupteurs pendant que des
ennemis réapparaissent à l'infini et ben
oui bien sûr faisons ça non et tout ça
pourquoi en plus ouvrir une de
grille fermée mais bordel de merde je
suis Hulk je l'encule la grille et de
toute façon c'est quoi tout ce niveau en
fait il y a des magiciens il y a des
énigmes c'est ouvert ne serait-ce qu'une
seule fois la première page d'un comic
de Hulk dans ta vie tu reviens pas en
10ant oui Hulk bien sûr ce fameux
détective qui parcourt les donjons en
raésol vant des énigmes enfin bon donc
on a beaucoup parlé des boss jusqu'à
présent mais il y a aussi des niveaux
entre ces boss et quoi de mieux pour un
jeu hulque qu'un jeu avec des
plateformes oui et pourquoi pas même des
plateformes de glace des plateformes de
glace avec un clipping à 4 CTIM devant
toi ve que ça s'arrête même les ennemis
il veulent en finir et je vous jure que
ce niveau entier c'est un test de
patience c'est n'importe quoi oui mais
qu'est-ce qu'il t'ont fait Hulk
qu'est-ce qu'il t'ont fait
il y a un mur mais non je fa
quoi mais regardez la distance
d'affichage de ce jeu est tellement à
chier que je voyais même pas la suite du
niveau c'était là que je devais aller
puain mais il a marché sur quoi
la plateforme qui est 10 m en dessous
sérieusement il y a plus de plateforme
dans ce jeu que dans le jeu megga Drive
qui pourtant était un jeu de plateforme
et je crois que le plus insupportable
c'est que la 3D est tellement
dégueulasse que tu as des trucs
mystiques qui se passent genre ce
passage je pourrais vous mettre 2 heur
d'image de moi en train de sauter à cet
endroit précis et voyez bien qu'il a un
trou làin vous voyez bien qu'il y a un
espace entre ces deux
[Musique]
blocs tu peux juste marcher
dessus tu peux juste marcher
dessus vous savez quoi nique ta mère je
dis plus rien allez voilà maintenant il
y a des saut de Lange et je peux pas
voir de sous en baissant mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas genre comme si la
mécanique existait depuis le premier
Sonic
mer qu'est-ce qu'ils font les ennemis
là il glisse il
bug c'est n'importe quoi mais
maintenant il y a des plateformes qui VO
il manque la moitié du décor au fond non
mais le jeu il s'arrête à ce niveau ils
ont laissé tomber attends attends quoi
comment il est mort comment ce boss est
mort il était full PV même en regardant
le ralenti je n'arrive pas à expliquer
comment ce boss est mort sérieusement
c'est du 0 sur 20 le jeu est pathétique
tout ce qui avait la moindre chance
d'être raté a été raté et également
qu'est-ce qu'il leur a pris pour les
derniers niveaux parce que après le
niveau de glace il n'y a plus de nouveau
niveau on va uniquement rejouer dans les
premiers levels ils se sont dit quoi
qu'on serait pris genre d'un accès de
nostalgie d'ailleurs on revient même au
passage d'Ajax sauf que cette fois tout
brûle ah d'accord ok ok donc ça en fait
ça va c'était du for shadowing en fait
les développeurs nous avaient appris
avant qu'il y avait un truc qui fait de
la pluie et c'est maintenant que ça
sert pas du tout je vois pas le rapport
voilà donc maintenant attention
concentrez-vous je vais vous expliquer
le boss final donc après des heures de
misère sexuelle dont je vous épargne le
contenu à la fin tu te bats contre le
boss final et en même temps que tu te
bats tu dois utiliser une pièce de
machine sur un ordinateur pièce de
machine que j'ai galéré à trouver parce
qu'elle se trouve dans ton menu Option
là où tu règles le niveau de la musique
des bruit parce que c'est évidemment là
que tu mets un objet de
quête cette pièce de machine déclenche
une énigme qui déclenche un puzzle que
tu dois réaliser en utilisant les autres
pièces de la machine que tu ramasses sur
les boss parce que oui pendant ce temps
là donc pendant que tu fais le puzzle
l'énigme et tout ça et bien en même
temps tu es poursuivi par l'intégralité
des boss du jeu qui entetemps sont
revenus à la vie c'est littéralement
comme essayer de jouer aux échecs tout
en se faisant ule voilà et j'ai beau
relire mon texte je ne comprends rien ce
que j'ai dit mais on s'en fout ce je de
merde est
fini vous avez fini le jeu non ah je
vous l'aveis dit c'est un incompétent il
ne fera pas sa part du travail je ne
resterai pas ici une seconde de
plus partez pas du
coup je pars si je veux vous pouvez pas
partir c'est
ça mais j'attends que vous partiez
d'abord suff pendant que nous perd du
temps
renforce il est fou cru
sanginaire de sang pas de
limite regard
[Musique]
per al tu vier
tu es prêt à aller au fond du
fun quoi Seigneur Suprême nous avons la
gemme l'énergie jaune est à
nous quoi parfait sais-tu pourquoi je
t'ai fait venir ici j'ai besoin de toi
pour une opération coup de point
[Musique]